let's get to audience questions for the
week starting with a question about the
stock market
hey David if the stock market crash
continues what are you going to do as a
result in terms of investments well
listen what I've been doing for the last
like eight to ten years is once a month
I buy a little more mutual funds and
what I'm going to be doing once a month
is buying a little more mutual funds and
not really thinking about it I mean that
that's if you know my investment
philosophy and of course this is not
investment advice to be clear I'm
telling you what I'm going to do and
this could be terrible advice for other
people this is not advice it is simply
what I am doing I don't try to time the
market my approach is on a regular basis
accumulate more and more shares of
mutual funds wide broad-based mutual
funds entire country total world stock
market index mix mixed in with a little
bit of bonds and when prices drop I just
keep buying and what is important to
remember is you don't really lose money
until you sell it a loss your unrealized
gains go down your losses go up
depending on whether you're up or down
but until you actually make the call to
sell that that stock or that those
mutual funds you don't really lose
anything you would if you sold but you
don't if you hold and what is really
important to consider is that dividends
actually tend to stay relatively level
even when stocks decline in value and
what that means is that when there is a
stock market correction assuming of
course that your time horizon is such
that you can you know a bear the
temporary reduction in stock prices
you're buying more dividends for fewer
dollars you're getting more shares if
you're putting in a hundred bucks a
month or however much it is that you're
putting in so I don't try to time the
market I will continue doing what I have
been doing for many many years if we are
indeed sort of at the beginning of a
stock market decline and eventually
we're going to be at one right I mean we
talk all the time pad about
economists are notoriously bad at
predicting exactly when these things are
going to happen but at some point
there's going to be a relatively
significant stock market correction and
if your time horizon allows for it what
you can do if you are of my investing
philosophy is do the exact same thing
yeah we're currently in the second
longest period of prosperity in American
history so you have to imagine it's
going to turn around at some point maybe
not today or tomorrow maybe it's next
year the year after that we show exactly
one don't know are you going to invest
in any precious metals because sometimes
when there is a stock market crash the
price of like gold and silver start to
go up that's a form of trying to time
certain sectors and I don't really do
that I have tiny little pieces of
precious metals companies because I'm
invested in the broadest possible mutual
funds in terms of stuff stock total US
stock index and total international
stock index so do I own some precious
metals there sure am I going to try to
move money from whatever you know any
something into precious metals as a
result of what I'm not gonna do that and
particularly because when you do that
you also accumulate taxes that you have
to pay if you have gains if you have
lost as you can write them off you incur
transaction fees depending on again what
it is that you're doing so my the lowest
possible cost I think I pay like point
oh five percent a year fees on the
mutual funds I have or something like
that lowest possible cost
fewest transactions just continue
accumulating and you know let 3040 years
go by if you have the time yeah if this
happens I think I'm gonna have to put my
day trading hobby on the backburner yes
and it sounds like bad news but it
probably will make me more productive
here I think so on a day to day basis
yeah that takes have a lot of time it
does and also the online poker playing
is probably time to uh to wrap that up